j'ai eu ma mère qui a eu copie de mon
petit frère qui a 9 ans aussi
heureusement les deux cas on pas été
grave mais on a été quand même très
inquiet donc
c'est vrai que le fait d'être vacciné
nous a empêchés d'avoir des formes
graves le pass vaccinale qui ont une
démarche intéressante après je comprends
pourquoi certaines personnes trouvent ça
inquitant et pubs être anxieux par
rapport à ça
mais je pense encore une fois que voilà
on essaye de faire ce qu'on peut pour
gérer les choses de façon
calme et correct
[Musique]
ben non je n'étais pas au courant je
savais qu'il y avait ce a augmenté en ce
moment c'est vrai qu'il ya pas ou plus
de
plusieurs en fait je trouve à l'école
moi dans mon école n'y a pas en l'onu
les yeux et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de cas qui se créent en fait en même
autour de moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui
attrape le peloton
[Musique]
je suis pas au courant qu'ils avaient
autant de cas j'avoue que je ne suis pas
forcément le nombre précis de nouveaux
cas tous les jours mais je sais que
globalement la période en ce moment
c'est c'est
je sais que c'est dans ces eaux là tous
les jours depuis quelques semaines
maintenant je suis pas de nature
à être forcément stressé par
en l'occurrence la par la maladie
d'autant plus que ces malheureux ça fait
deux ans que ça dure il ya des au débat
mais au final
ça commence à faire un moment donc on
est plus ou moins habitués à vivre avec
donc on est moins stressé que les
premières semaines
eh bien pas du tout et puis alors je
vais vous dire ça m'intéresse absolument
pas ça m'intéresse mais alors à un point
non franchement ça va se passer et puis
voilà on est arrivé à la fin non on
n'est pas arrivé à la fin
[Musique]